je vois bien désormais vous faites
attention à ce que vous dites Rachida
heureusement heureusement ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas interview dit pas
dit Rachida
Dati Rachida bonsoir alors d'abord
Rachida merci d'être là malgré une
semaine très chargée le bureau politique
de l'UMP votre réélection au Parlement
européen les sols de priv c'est
Dior merci
r vous avez donc été réélu
successivement maire du 7e
arrondissement de Paris et député
européenne député européenne ça veut
dire ça veut dire Strasbourg quoi le le
cauchemar ne finira jamais
quoi Parlement européen c'est une fois
par mois Strasbourg le reste c'est
Bruxelles mais ça va maintenant la la
déception de votre réélection est passé
ça
va c'est pas gentil pour les électeurs
ouais vous allez pleur pendant 3 jours
en disant je veux pas y retourner elle
déteste la preuve je suis tellement Maou
que je me suis représenté oui voilà
alors en revanche bonne nouvelle
Nathalie kochusco maisé n'a pas été élue
à Paris alors ça ça réjouiss son nous
mais réjouissons nous de quoi vous la
connaissez elle
fait vous le faites bien non moi j'ai eu
quelques désaccords au moment de la
campagne la manière de faire campagne
mais je l'ai dit je lui ai dit à elle et
je l'ai dit publiquement mais dès lors
on peut dire exprimer des désaccords qui
ne sont pas des hostilités on considère
ça comme des hostilités des détestations
moi j'ai on appartient à la même famille
politique on peut avoir des désaccords
il y a une chose quand même c'est que
tous les élus de Paris devaient donner
5000 € pour la campagne de Nathalie
kochusco morisé vous avez toujours pas
donné le PO parce que non non mais
d'abord je ne suis pas la seule à ne pas
avoir contribué à la campagne de
Nathalie parce que chacun dans un
arrondissement on finance notre campagne
moi j'ai financé ma campagne et après
vous pouvez donner à la candidate mais
et simplement le fait de financer la
campagne du 7e arrondissement est une
contribution à la campagne parisienne
donc j'ai financé la campagne VO et
voilà elle aura pas de poignon voilà
alors autre bonne nouvelle le calme est
quand même revenu à à
l'UMP ça
l'air vousz bien le calme est revenu
enfin moi je recherche pas le calme on
s'oppose plus le chômage explose la
délinquence explose le sujet c'est pas
le calme c'est le sujet de s'occuper de
la France nos électeurs nos militants
moi je m'en fiche des pas trop le temps
ils ont pas trop le temps de s'occuper
de la France ils sont occupés bah oui
alors cette hisoire big Malion moi je
sais pas Natacha si vous comprenez
quelque chose moi je comprends pas
pourquoi le nom de de Nicolas Sarkozi a
été cité dans cette obscure affaire de
financement de la campagne de Nicolas
Sarkozy en effet a priori comment
pourrait-il être au courant de ce que
font ces lieutenants qui l'a mis là pour
être au courant de tout ce qui se
passait c'est
très Ron vous avez une société une
entreprise est-ce que vous êtes au
courant de tout ce que fait votre expert
comptable votre
comptable bah voilà et donc quand il est
candidat il a autre chose à penser que
de voir les aspects logistiques ou
techniques donc faut arrêter de mélanger
les choses je dis que dans cette affaire
faut faire très attention à ce qu'on dit
et certains s'il veulent viser Sarkozi
nommément pour un objectif faut être
clair dans la vie faut pas prendre comme
prétexte big malallon ou autre chose
pour dire Nicolas Sarkozy est en cause
donc il doit dégager faut dire je t' pas
je te veux pas tu dégages c'est plus
clut ê courageuxut être courageux pour
dire ça c'est vrai vous avez raison de
alors autre bonne nouvelle le supplément
de New York Magazine the cut vous a
classé 9e parmi les 40 françaises les
plus
stylé moi je suis ravi je suis ravi
parce que enfin enfin votre action
politique est estimé à sa juste valeur
coup vous êtes vraiment un mais
pour
[Applaudissements]
attende je suis en train de vous dire
que je me réjouis que vous soyez
réjou de venir à votre émission et c'est
double peine c'est pas dou c'est la
vérité c'est une vérité pas la deè
partie ah la deè partie oui d'accord
attendezalie faites pas de fixette et
alors Carla non plus que Carla brun
n'est pas dans les françaises les plus
sty dire que se promener avec Sarkozi en
accessoire à son bras finalement ça fait
pas ça fait pas de vous une femme chic
voilà c'est tout alors vous tenez en
forme Rachida vous entraînez beaucoup
hein vous hein vous faites du non vous
faites de la boxe attendez Rachida vous
faites de la box avec Franck petitjan ch
oh mais mais c'est cette histoire non
mais c'est quelqu'un
qui le pauvre il m'a donné quelques
cours il se retrouve de h mais il y a
pas de honte de honte pas la bonne idée
de fr c'est qu'il a mis un portrait de
Fillon sur le ping B donc vous tapez
beaucoup plus fort voilà il a peut-être
changé depuis d'ailleurs dans les
portraits là vous préparez votre droite
pour le congrès de l'UMP non mais c'est
c'est normal Rach je crois que ma droite
ça fait longtemps
travaille bon de toute façon je vois
bien désormais vous faites attention à
ce que vous dit Rachida heureusement
heureusement ça n'a pas toujours été le
cas interview dit pas dit ah
si attention je n'ai jamais
instrumentalisé ma vie privée dis pas
dit fait ou pas fait ça on a la réponse
mais dit pas dit ça je ne sais pas fait
ou pas fait non mais là c'est encore
elle dit Rach jamais instrumentalis ma
vie privé ce qui est vrai est-ce que
vous savez qui je vis comment je vis et
quelle est ma vie non jamais on en parle
tous les jours mais on sait pas voilà
donc donc je l'ai pas instrumatalisé
attention se concentre j'ai demandé à ce
que Christian Dior soit le parrain de ma
fille à titre
Postume vraim je dirais non non pas dit
pas
dit vu la taille de son nez et de ses
oreilles Nicolas Sarkozi doit avoir un
énorme sexe bien sûr que oui mais bien
sûr que oui mais évidemment Rachida n'a
jamais dit ça
mais moi qui demander à mon père de
regarder l'émission mais c'est pasa papa
elle l'a pas dit elle l'a pas dit ellea
pas dit dit c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
vrai si je devais quitter la politique
je pourrais redevenir caissière à fond
prix ah bien sûr bien sûr par ben voilà
bien oui je sais attendez il y en a une
je sais pas si elle est par ça j'ai
dormi à côté de Jean-Louis borlau qui
ronf il n'est pas très sexy il pu des
pieds j'avais le gerbillon
ou alors c un sm pr j'ai peur que ça
soit vrai ça a une partie vraie il y a
une partie qui est vrai c'est qu' pue
des pieds non j'ai pas Ditis gerillant
non j'ai jamais dit ça non parce que je
sais que en plus B ber m'a engueulé
après ou et c'était dans l'avion hein il
faut préciser c'était lors d'un
voyage non non mais dormir et tout bien
sûr non mais non mais c'est important
c'est important de le dire parce que il
y a schunberg qui est là franchement
entre Cécilia et Carla il y a pas photo
je préfère largement Cécilia à l'autre
momie mais vous êtes dégueulasse non
mais c'est pas vrai alors mais dit non
non j'aime beaucoup Cécilia j'ai jamais
dit que je
préféis à l'ut mie vous préférez
Cie mais commence à tirer des emmerdes
il est fort parce que il regarde dans
les yeux ah bon c'est pas vrai alors ça
vous l'avez jamais dit l'autre momie
c'est pas vrai non oh non la France
alors ça c'est énorme la France était un
moteur pour le monde grâce à Nicolas
Sarkozi je peux l'avoir dit ça peux
dire coucher en politique ça me dérange
pas c'est coucher sans but qui m'énerve
ah non mais vous c'est dégueulasse ah
vous avez vu la classe
politique
ouais ça c'est et la dernière quand je
vois certains VO là qui réclam une
rentabilité à 20 25 % avec une
fation quasi nulle ça veut dire qu'on
casse les entreprises mais
ouilation cétait merveilleux d'ailleurs
en tout cas ça bien fait rire mes
collègues parlementaires européens parce
quand je suis revenu notamment les
Espagnols il me parlent bien la fait
la et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu